[Music]
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between quiznos in the uk and the us
this is food wars
in the uk quiznos sandwiches come in
four sizes firstly we have the kids size
which is four and a half inches then we
have a small sub which is six inches a
medium sub from uk quiznos is nine
inches or at least it should be before
we got hungry and ate it by mistake and
then finally we have a large sub which
is 12 inches or one foot long in the u.s
our quizno sandwiches come in four sizes
the sami a four inch an eight inch and a
twelve inch
and i wanna give quiznos props for not
calling this like a sandwich taco or
something really obnoxious
also in the u.s out of quiznos you can
get party platters of either 20 3-inch
sandwiches or 14 flatbreads cut in half
there are no fountain drinks that are
quizzlers in the uk instead we just have
cans and bottles which are 330
milliliters and 500 milliliters
respectively
in the u.s at a quiznos you can use
drinks in three sizes either a bottle
which is 20 ounces the regular also 20
ounces or the large which they did not
have
let's weigh a classic italian footlong
from a quiznos in the uk to see what it
comes to
so our scales could just about handle
that turns out that a footlong classic
italian from a uk quiz knows is 520
grams
in the u.s quiznos classic footlong
italian is
about like
460.
quiznos was one of the first chains to
toast their subs so now let's
arbitrarily compare the toastedness
between our bread and the uk bread
in our extremely precise comparison
metric it looks like the u.s maybe has
the edge when it comes to toastiness of
the bread the inside of this is
completely soggy and the outside just
very average
[Music]
here is everything you'll only find on
the menu at a quiznos in the uk
and here are a lot
of the usa quiznos exclusive items let's
start with some sandwich options first
the first one is this one it's a vegan
pakora sandwich pakora is an indian food
which is made of chopped and spiced
onions and opening this i got a real hit
of some really nice flavors actually
it's actually really good
very flavourful next up we've got one
which i'm surprised wasn't on the us
menu which is a blt
you can also get a periphery chicken
from uk quiznos peri-peri chicken is
just like a kind of chili marinated
chicken which has a little bit of heat
to it another slightly surprising
exclusive in that i'm surprised you
don't have it in the us is the barbecue
chicken they've given us a small sub but
it looks like they've written smell on
it so
for the meat lovers we have a barbecue
steak and pepperoni sub then we have a
classic british filling which is this
one ham cheese and pickle now when we
say pickle here we don't mean slices of
pickled cucumber what we mean is pickle
which is a brown vinegary condiment made
with various vegetables
oh no they actually do mean pickle
don't mean actual pickle next up we've
got the zesty steak sub i'm not exactly
sure what makes this zesty so i'm going
to try it and try and find
out i'd be lying if i said this was the
zestiest thing i've ever eaten there's
some kind of like salsa on the top which
i guess is supposed to be the zesty
component but
basically not much flavor coming from it
perhaps the meatiest option on the whole
menu is the three meat stack so it looks
as if the three meats are ham bacon and
beef but there's also some olives in
there some lettuce tomato and cheese and
then lastly we have a double cheese melt
this is basically just a grilled cheese
but in sub form
the chipotle turkey wheats it looks all
right
the honey baking all this honey in this
dude a honey bacon club
yeah i can get down on that the
southwest chicken on the
jalapeno bread
i don't know it kind of looks kind of
rough in there this veggie sandwich is
packed with veggies man veggie on wheat
all you health nuts out there the black
angus this one i don't know about this
one i think having black angus i guess
like shaved steak with the spicy
monterey
turkey club overflowing with turkey
clubbiness
next up we have toasties toasties are a
very popular lunch snack in the uk it's
what we call a grilled cheese so if you
go to the uk and ask for a toasty that's
what you get toasties at quiznos come in
the form of cheese ham and cheese and
tuna mayo
in the u.s you can get a quizno sandwich
in sami form and what that kind of looks
like is a i don't know if it's a pita
bread but it's kind of folded over you
saw it earlier we go with the instant
replay of the sammy
that thing you can't get those in the uk
from my understanding and i don't know
if you can get every sandwich sammied
you can get the classic italian
black angus the lobster and the slow
roasted chicken
i have to say like i thought it was
stupid but this actually like looks more
manageable if you want to try something
out it's been sitting for a while but
like looks a little bit like a gordita
next up we've got crispy chicken fillets
these are basically just breaded and
fried chicken tenders and they come in
portions of four six or eight
on the side in the uk you can get a
portion of crisscut fries these come as
small or large and they're just potato
that's cut into a crisscross pattern and
deep fried
our last hot side option is garlic bread
it looks like it's made with the same
bread that quiznos uses for most of
their subs in the uk have there's some
garlic butter spread on top of it and
then it's toasted as well you can also
get this with cheese
tater tats in the u.s of a regular and
jalapeno bacon
yeah whoa
i brought a bit right into a jalapeno
okay
slow down joe
pizza time pizza time in the uk quiznos
offers a range of pizzas we're gonna go
through them one by one to show you what
they are
let's start with this one now this one
is the chicken baja which is a barbecue
sauce based pizza with some bacon some
barbecue chicken some kind of baja sauce
i presume and some red onion as well our
next pizza option is the peri-peri
chicken this one's pretty
straightforward it's pre-prairie chicken
peppers and onions
from there we're moving on to the veggie
supreme this is a vegetarian friendly
option with some peppers mushrooms
onions and olives
then we're moving on to the bbq chicken
pizza this one has a barbecue sauce base
some barbecue chicken and then once
again peppers and onions i personally
hate it when they use barbecue sauce as
the base instead of tomato sauce like it
ain't broke don't fix it then finally we
have the classics margarita and
pepperoni really not much to say about
these
christmas in the uk also offers a range
of wraps and salads the following things
can be used in either form
chicken caesar barbecue chicken and
ranch
tuna honey mustard chicken peri-peri
chicken and mediterranean salad
soups
this was this chili
ooh cheddar brown i'm going to open this
cheddar broccoli sorry dude
yeah ugh it's not that this is a bad
version of the soup
it's that cheddar broccoli or cheese
broccoli i mean this smells exactly like
a fart and everyone's favorite chicken
noodle
salads
you can get a side garden salad
like the lops are supposed to be like a
thing for them so you can also get
lobster salad
and that
actually looks pretty good uh this is
the uh i think the chef salad
uh the italian salad which i think is
everything that comes on the italian
sandwich
thrown in a bowl
and then finally we have some snack
options christmas in the uk offers these
real branded crisps which come as sea
salt or cheese and onion flavor we can
get a fruits and oat cookie from a uk
christmas
the packaging advertises this as a giant
cookie but to me this is just a regular
sized cookie so i don't know if all the
workers at paterson's are just very
small or if they need to change their
terminology
and finally we have two muffin options
chocolate or blueberry these fantastic
chips are available at quiznos in the us
uh miss vicki has a bunch of different
brands on top of that at quiznos you can
get so many other types of chips let's
get a few of those on the screen right
now
quiznos in the u.s we got your chips
covered
getting great audio as i cut us right in
front of a mic
unfortunately quiznos in the uk doesn't
expose any of its nutritional
information so i'm just gonna sit here
and like think about pokemon i guess
[Music]
what's pokemon at quiznos in the u.s a
classic italian 12 inch sub is 1260
calories 63 grams of fat 22 grams of
saturated fat
3760 milligrams of sodium and 115 grams
of carbs if you're worried about sodium
i got some bad news
throw in a bag
of the lovely miss vicki's sea salt
chips
arguably the best flavor of miss vicky's
chips the sea salt it's like sea salt
and who cares love these chips and
a large coke
yes more that's a regular can we get
someone in post to make that bigger
thank you
add these two things and now your meal
is
2040 calories 84 grams of fat 25 of
those grams of saturated 4 290
milligrams of sodium and
264 grams of carbos for those of you
with the sweet tooth if you want to
substitute the chips for a cookie
for a cookie
[Music]
[Music]
for a cookie
now you got the cooking set of the chips
with the large coke still you're going
to go up to
2133 calories 81 grams of fat 33 grams
of a saturated fat
4 100 milligrams of sodium and
279 grams of carbs
is it a jew or a juice thank you
this life-saving device stops are you
kidding me this video is two seconds
long
great thanks guys
in the us a french dip 12 inch with
ojoo
right is 1140 calories 45 grams of fat
14 saturated fat 3 370 milligrams of
sodium and 119 carbs now connor i gotta
get personal for a second here the last
time i ate at quiznos was probably 12
years ago i worked in an office job that
i really hated in the lobby was a
quiznos
and i went there one day with a
co-worker got a sandwich and on the way
out that co-worker said to me what'd you
think and i believe my exact words were
you'd have to pay me to eat at quiznos
again 12 years later
they're paying me to eat a
quiznos dude
this is pretty good
this is not the most calorific sandwich
on a quizno's menu that distinguished
honor goes to the 12-inch italian
meatball it's
390 calories for one 12-inch sandwich
this sandwich is pretty good this
dipping thing this don't work i don't
want this cold dip coming with my
sandwich when i get home and i want to
do all this in the quiznos and i
certainly can't do this in the car
quiznos listen to me i'm about to give
you a million dollar idea so check this
out you guys with some food science do
what the mcgriddle did
right with the syrup in their in their
pancake buns you do the same thing you
inject
this juice into the bread of the
sandwich so it's all in one that'd be
amazing dude i would totally get the
sandwich is this not a bad idea no
dipping right i just saved the brand
you're welcome i think i deserve a
quizno's black card now our american
audience might be wondering quiznos
didn't they go out of business and the
answer is not really and apparently they
might be making a comeback research on
the brand shows that between 2007 and
2017
quiznos went from 4 700 us locations to
fewer than 400 they had a fierce
competitor in subway jimmy john's and
several other small sandwich chains they
were hit hard by the great recession and
had to deal with several lawsuits from
many of their own franchisees
in 2014 quizzes actually filed for
chapter 11 bankruptcy in the us but it
looks like some of their stores stuck
around according to a recent article we
found in qsr magazine which does read
awfully like a press release quiznos is
moving forward with new designs menu
items and drive-throughs so perhaps the
future is bright i hate to break it to
you all these sandwich places are almost
exactly the same so there's no reason
why quiznos can't be just as popular as
any other ones right especially now like
doing like kind of a comeback what they
have to do pay attention quiz now is
more information coming your way what
quiznos has to do is go after each
sandwich chain individually and just
position themselves as not being that
and picking the thing that sucks about
it just being like hey we don't have
that like you want to beat subway
quiznos yoga mat material free in the
bread there you go give another sandwich
please this is easy go give me one yeah
dude correct me wrong but like jimmy
john's their whole thing was like they
make sandwiches super fast right in
order to do that it's like one person
slices the bread then the next person
cuts the meat right and that's pushed as
the cheese why it's like five people
touch your sandwich to make it go faster
quiznos your sandwich won't be touched
by five stone teenagers
pot bellies nobody wants to eat in an
antique store
at quiznos our furniture isn't 100 years
old what's left
jersey mike's quiznos we're not from new
jersey
[Music]